[Music]
Joe you have mentioned Jake Paul's
online thingy huh Jake paulien Academy
we talked about you think about I have
it I wanted to actually get his course
and check it out because I can't only
$20 a month yeah I know but I haven't
looked at it personally so I don't know
what to make of it yeah cuz I want to
actually do it and then say if it's good
or bad or whatever that's good content
cuz it might be good huh yeah it might
be eyes did Jake Paul's course for a
month and here's what happened
oh do you do it do it do it do it
actually no the team that he's working
with and they're legit guys so yeah okay
I don't know yeah so I don't know what
to make of it Jake Paul has launched
financial freedom movement which is an
online platform offering an education
from Jake Paul and other influencers on
how to monetize their creative interests
for $20 a month it's pretty cool yeah I
will play to you guys yeah but the
internet doesn't like them so we can't
like this yeah oh this is stupid
you we have we have fans that are his
fans too so some for them oh this is
cool oh cool for the general internet
for the yeah for the haters yeah [ __ ]
this guy yeah [ __ ] him he's done so we
got both sides card on us you got both
sides see that's why it's cool we have
multiple people in the show so like some
of us can support it and some of us
don't hit tonight you could be the one
that does it
yeah okay Paul [ __ ] Stewart you're
not on the internet you're like who's
Jake Paul Dan you could be the who's
Jake Paul guy okay boomer you're like
man how is no mommy much okay I'm gonna
play I like it when a boomer does a
Boomer version
I smash again which is here what is this
game of Thrones cuz winter is here too
chilly here we go
they say you were entitled and lazy they
tell us not to get a job retire at 65
how's that working out for us are your
parents happy are they living the life
they want it the music's over 1 million
dollars in student loan debt
really motivation without data education
who can't even get a job yep for the
student loans they took out that now
haunt them for life they even were too
young to have experienced a I know but
then you know exactly what I'm owed of a
tional knows I deliver before I get
ready to move islands we deserve better
we're smarter so what's the solution
we need a criminal's rent for our
generation one that inspires people to
take action to achieve their dream now
the dreams our parents have for us or
our society we need a movement that
inspires people don't live like that not
someone else's a movement that anyone
who's gracious enough to follow can have
a much higher chance of becoming
financially free from the societal
cookie cutter nine-to-five jobs we were
all told to have our future is in our
hands
just try it with me are you all are you
with him the digital sounds sick he
makes some fair points yeah for sure I
agree with all of it you know what like
it to me one of my missions though is to
teach this alternative education of
success and if he has really good
information and he can give value I'm
all for it because we do need this new
movement like the the school system is
archaic [ __ ] outdated everybody wants
to frolic like that girl frolic in the
video yeah that'd be pretty slow mo yeah
I have friends who are in academia that
work in universities and there's so much
[ __ ] politics red tape money being
skimmed off they it drives them sick
they're like it's it's crazy man I mean
there's waste there's a lot of waste a
lot of politics a lot of disk run
old administrators and professors is
just a great incest the good news is
they all want to help these kids right
they're passionate that's right
here's the thing even beyond all that if
everything even worked the way it's
supposed to like you know so many people
I like I used to work out when I was in
high school I worked out from know when
I was a freshman in college I worked at
footlocker right next to a dude that had
a degree in business you know saying it
so it's like yeah the degree got him uh
like he had a salary instead of me just
working minimum wage but it was still
kind of like what's the point did he get
to where the the the jersey thing but
you didn't get to wear that
oh no we both had to black oh did he
have a LAN yard there no whistles at
footlocker we're not referees buddy man
didn't have referee shirts oh yeah no
but you're right I mean that that's
exactly you're saying is right so I
don't disagree with anything Jay Paul
just said does anybody know it's just
the way he looks you just want to punch
him in the face for some [ __ ] you
know the fiery like you know I got
everything he's saying is ice on your
lips but it's just the way he delivers
it feel sleazy me with everything that
he's saying
jeah would you rather he did this that
looked like slow motion almost but you
got it you got it
the thing is that everyone's criticizing
this because it's like wait it's called
financial freedom movement but you want
me to pay my money to learn this that's
mine but that's how life is that part
makes perfect pain for a [ __ ] pro
wait it's called financial freedom
movement and I have to go somewhere and
pay my gas to get there like what the
[ __ ] dude I'm cynical can you be you're
paying for a class yeah part that people
are heavily criticizing is the fact that
this isn't the first course online
course that Jay Paul has launched he had
previously launched ed fluence which was
a series of educational courses designed
to teach people how to become
social media famous and it cost users
$64 to take advantage of all its perks
and if you now go to that website it
doesn't exist so people are like what's
buck are there any testimonial but that
just means he created a product and then
he's just cancelling and starting over I
mean nobody has to pay $64 for anything
like that it's a voluntary thing yeah
right like I could say it I got a Steve
green course there's a hundred twenty
bucks and I'm not an [ __ ] for that
cuz it nobody has to buy it oh it's your
choices like honestly like I don't need
to pay whatever a month to go to the gym
I could do crunches in my yeah that's
what I don't understand is why people
are outraged when you don't have to pay
for it it's a demo that's really
outraged it's more like they're laughing
at him right see okay so it's the crink
it's like do people do this [ __ ] to of
like what a hypocrite because of this
and it's like it's not really that's not
really hypocrisy like he just opened
another business and they just try
something different yeah yeah and he
probably took everything he learned from
the last businesses planned to this one
so to me it's just its evolution right
it is and I mean if there's an if
there's anybody who was able to not go
to college and make a lot of high school
well pleaded his high school through an
online course well here's the thing
right a lot of people are they're
limiting beliefs and their reality is
kind of in a completely different space
right so when they look at situations
like this they go well what I see is
someone who got lucky and all they're
doing is saying hey this is how I got
lucky
pay me to let me just gloat how lucky I
am and here's how to do it but what a
lot of people are thinking is you're
just selling a dream and it's not
reality because where they are at life
where their world is everyone around
them their parents society everyone
their reality is go to school and then
you get a normal 9 to 5 job right mm-hmm
but for us we know that being surrounded
by entertainers entrepreneurs be free
freelancers people that went off and
decided to create their own like path
for life it's very possible right
everybody that I know of every [ __ ] I
don't
buddy of every race and [ __ ] who has
money right now yeah and they all just
did the same thing they open businesses
for themselves
yeah well in their asses off for me it's
always this is what I tell people to
like you're looking so high like it's
difficult to make a fortune off your
passion but it's very easy to just earn
a living off of your passion like if you
really [ __ ] work at it I've seen the
work at it yeah I've seen so many people
do that right but then the reality for
most people though they don't think that
it's a possibility so to me I'm like
you're already failing before you start
it so these are through this right the
darlings and so these were these
programs and a lot of these things it's
really about shifting that perspective
and helping you climb out of that and a
lot of I think a lot of snake oil
salesmen and weirdos can get into it
just the same way a lot of people can
get into religion and manipulate the the
followers in religion or just everything
where it relies upon kind of mentoring
someone and coaching someone and
changing their life I think that type of
industry is susceptible to scams but
most there's every every every industry
has a con well there's no high percent
success rate right like I could go to
Jake Paul or Tony Robbins or whatever
and if I go there that doesn't guarantee
that I'm gonna [ __ ] in I got a hundred
percent success rate because I went to
Tony Robbins but that's why school is
such a fraud because if you follow and
do the work to me it's bare minimum work
it's not it's not high level [ __ ] right
you get your degree and you feel this
sense of you finished and got something
that's gonna take you somewhere but it's
a scam because you get this degree
especially now and then you have what
forty thousand in debt at least people
feel like they're promised after they
get a certain degree or certification
get up as you get high pay hold up this
you get you get a better job whatever
right yeah and then what really happens
nothing
exactly exactly I would always tell
people whenever people are like you know
how does it feel to be living your
dreams I feel I was something like yo I
never looked at it like a dream you know
I'm saying like I looked at pursuing the
entertainment
business industry the way you would look
at like my homegirl Bree who when we
were freshmen in high school I told her
I wanted to be a famous entertainer she
wanted to be a doctor so for her I feel
like she went through the necessary
steps you know taking like all these
classes becoming a nurse becoming and
then finally going to med school being a
doctor for me I looked at it the same
way I'm like I know what I want to do so
I'm gonna like put myself in the right
places I'm like entertainment wise I'm
gonna take little parts here I'm gonna
put myself out there and I'm gonna go to
auditions keep doing just a bunch of
little things because I feel like as
long as you keep doing little things you
I mean where can you really go but
forward in it you know you do do some of
those too yeah I wanna yeah yeah I do I
do College speaking engagements here you
also have to do things that you don't
you've started self motivate yourself
like I wrote [ __ ] ten scripts without
anybody paying me yeah I wrote ten
movies without anybody ever paying me to
do it I sat there and [ __ ] wrote it
and [ __ ] grinded on it and then try
to improve it and then revised it why
nobody's there telling me to revise it
I'm revising it trying to make it better
so like I motivate myself to do that
before I ever got to sell anything so if
you can just if you could just you're
we're all competing with people out
there right there's there's there's
other screenwriters out there competing
with me right now as I'm writing right
but the beauty is that I know that if I
work hard enough I'm beating so many
other people who aren't I'm beating the
guy who's sitting at Starbucks right now
and maybe he opened up into the window
and he's [ __ ] off right like I'm
meeting the guy who tells his wife that
he's writing tonight but then he doesn't
yeah like I'm beating all those guys
you're beating the dude that got a
degree for screenwriting but then gave
up because maybe he didn't sell his
first script exactly brother and all
those haters are just going on comments
of screenwriters and movie creators or
whatever and just criticizing them but
they're just jacking off at home all day
hey basically yeah and so I'm already
beating those guys right the guys are
jacked off all day I'm beating them too
so if you can put yourself in a position
where you're motivated enough to win for
yourself you're gonna be beating a lot
of people who aren't gonna be doing that
too and that's how you [ __ ] rise up
and that's why I created my programs
baby jamali and academy.com all the
basic information at school and your
parents should have taught you
completely free I give this as just for
thanks to my fans and another one 90
days
because everything we talked about today
you do need to free your mind in order
to get into whatever you want to do
without limiting your mind you got to
break out of that
I tried Joe Milan Academy for 30 days
and I tripled my income but more so I
tripled my mindset there we go
how would you do Jay Paul it's free
[Music]
[Music]